[Music]
I'm subterra Mukherjee I head the
product marketing function for our data
analytics business and today I have the
privilege to to be joined by David na
Renan and David is a distinguished
engineer from Home Depot one of our
iconic bigquery customers and then vivek
Yadav and vivek is a customer
engineering lead for google cloud and
today we are going to talk to you about
how enterprises are reimagining what's
possible with a data warehouse and how
they're essentially going beyond the
conventional use cases of operational
reporting and bi against bigquery and
building some of the things that are
incredible like for example Home Depot
built a planet scale application and
Network log monitoring system for their
organization so before we get into the
home depot story why are we trying to
reimagine what's possible with data
warehouse and why data warehouse is in
the epicenter of all this conversation
if you look at fundamentally what has
happened over the course of last few
years enterprises are experiencing an
astronomical growth with data and whom
Depot last year talked about how did
they move from their traditional data
warehouse system to bigquery to handle
scale and have more agility and that is
true for many organizations because
traditional data warehouses were not
designed for this amount of data
explosion and the other thing is when
enterprises are not able to ingest store
process that large amount of data not
only coming from traditional sources
like ERP or CRM system versus sources
like web clicks or IOT sensors or
application log etc then they are
essentially creating a lot of data silos
and they are not able to get the most
out of their data and this is a start
from Harvard Business Review it says
like enterprises today I typically
analyze less than 1% of unstructured
data and less than 50% of structured
data and we we are trying to change that
why data warehouse because data
management and data analytics is not not
just not confined to a warehousing
platform this is from Gartner they are
one of the leading industry
in the data management space they say
fundamentally data warehouses are still
the foundation of a company's analytic
strategy I think the I started my career
as a data warehousing engineer before I
became a marketeer and I remember the
days when we used to kind of essentially
create very specific operational reports
on a specific set of dimensions and
facts for our business users world has
evolved a lot and we kind of swung the
other way too started thinking about
data lakes are going to be the ultimate
solution for a lot of the big data
problems and now enterprises are
realizing like hey that possibly is not
the solution we need to refocus on
modernizing the data warehouse to handle
scale and address the modern business
requirements from the warehouse so as I
was kind of reflecting back like what's
the what has been the evolution of the
data warehouse and data warehouse is not
a use case and David is going to talk
about how they are using the warehouse
to do something that was not possible
before like application log monitoring
in 90s when possibly many of you started
working on warehouse may not have
started working that time operational
reporting was the core essence and the
way it was designed was for few users
will run a specific set of queries that
were predefined and optimized and this
will be the best performance the queries
running against the warehouse then came
the era of 2000 when enterprises started
realizing the fact that customers want
to do ad hoc analysis they want to run
self-service bi queries were not
predefined and business users were able
to essentially create queries on the fly
and the kernel that was supporting the
warehouse needed to essentially optimize
queries on-the-fly in the early 2010
I would say the era of data mining came
in where it was not just good enough to
look at the business from retrospect
what is happening on my sales but why
certain things are happening so you will
see a lot of data warehouses started
adopting data mining functions
essentially correlation causality came
in bigquery we do support some of these
and I'm going to talk about it and now
as we stand today what is happening with
data warehouses is businesses are trying
to get predictive insights
it's not just okay to look at the data
from retrospect it is important to
understand what's going to happen to the
business based on the last X number of
years of data or X days of data that I
have in my warehouse so the evolution is
really important to understand so if you
are operating against a traditional
warehouse and you just want to move it
to Google Cloud to do the same set of
use cases possibly you'll underserve
your business because a lot of things
that were not possible in the warehouse
in the past is possible today so those
of you I'm sure many of you have already
been using bigquery some of you in knew
bigquery is our enterprise data
warehousing platform it's designed for
massive scalability we are seeing
customers who are using bigquery for
terabytes of data processing - customers
you're using for hundreds of petabytes
of data processing using bigquery it's
highly encrypted durable and on the
right side if you see some of the things
that are unique to bigquery for example
its server less and in the home depot
example we'll hear why server less is so
important because we have B couple
system engineering from data analysis if
you are streaming data into the bigquery
service you need not need to worry about
load balancing like hey if I stream data
into the service is it going to impact
my query performance is it going to
impact user experience some of those
automations have been taken care of by
Google Google bigquery supports
real-time data analysis and this is
extremely important because data
warehouses were designed for batch
paradigm the reason why it was designed
was when you load data into the
warehouse the kernel cannot
simultaneously address a lot of query
requests coming from multiple user
that's why back in the days when I used
to work as a data warehouse person load
data on the night in the morning 8:00
a.m. fresh reports were served to
management people that paradigm has
completely shifted Home Depot for
example is streaming data in real time
from multiple systems to do analysis on
that data King as an example here
they're one of the largest gaming
companies the makers of the candy crush
saga
this essentially stream billions of
events in real time into the warehouse
and do analysis on gaming telemetry ml
is built into bigquery beaker ml you
have heard about the announcement we
have gone beyond just traditional
regression we support now came in
clusterings matrix factorization and
other of Gordon's for you to do lot of
ML related use cases and that we
announced bi engine and that's allowing
customers to do essentially concurrent
access on highly accelerated datasets
for subsequent queries on on bi datasets
so as I said bigquery is serverless I'm
not gonna spend much time I'm sure you
have seen versions of this fundamentally
bigquery abstracts a lot of the things
on the gray and the black that you see
the monitoring or provisioning indexing
disk defragmentation nothing is needed
you essentially put the data in and you
start querying the data so this is at a
very high level what is big queries
architecture is if your family or you
know this bigquery has a decoupled
storage and compute layer so essentially
when you stream data in or you bulk load
the data into the storage system the
query engine can essentially operate
independently and it allows you to scale
those two things independently of each
other
it has a streaming buffer so that allows
you to essentially use bigquery stream
API to insert up to hundred thousand
rows per second we can essentially
increase those soft limits if the
requirement be and then on the right
side bigquery has a great programming
layer on top of it so if you want to
programmatically access bigquery data
from the applications for further
analysis that's possible so I wanted to
kind of make things real a little bit
and give you some examples of how the
traditional mold of data warehousing has
been broken by many customers and these
are some of the examples one example
that comes to my mind is Zulily
and there are an e-commerce company they
essentially stream in up to 5 billion
events a day into bigquery in real-time
and they use those essentially use click
user click events on their website to do
personalized recommendation for their
product launches that they do in
website so again an example customers
are doing real-time analytics against
their data warehouse the second example
is a 20th Century Fox and 20th Century
Fox essentially is using bigquery to do
predictive analytics they are doing user
segmentation for their new movie
releases they are essentially bringing
bringing in their marketing analysts to
do segmentation using bigquery ml and
then disseminating that insights with
their organization and then AirAsia
there have been one of our key customers
for the BI engine launch they were doing
alpha testing with us and AirAsia is
essentially storing a lot of their
important data sets in bigquery and now
what they're doing is they're allowing
their non-technical business users
frontline users to use data shoot data
studio and sheets to connect that data
connect with the data and analyze the
data so essentially if you think about
again traditional enterprises enterprise
data warehouse few user playing with the
data from that multiple user groups are
playing with the same data
simultaneously and there are many more
examples where customers have done
incredible job with what's possible with
the data warehouse so it's time to
reimagine and see something new that we
haven't talked in the past before and
Home Depot team over the last year or so
built a planet-scale
application monitoring system using
bigquery so they're using their core
data warehouse to do something that we
haven't seen in the past so I like to
welcome David from Home Depot to share
his experience Thank You SAP hello it's
good to be with you this morning so last
year at next a couple of my colleagues
were here talking about how we migrated
our enterprise data warehouse to
bigquery and that was a huge effort but
it was a tremendous success for our
company so today I'd like to talk about
a completely different use case for
bigquery maybe a little bit
non-traditional but I would like to talk
about how we're using it for operational
data but first just a little bit of
background about the Home Depot we're
the world's largest home improvement
Tayler we have about 2300 stores and
about 150 supply chain facilities across
the US Canada and Mexico while we're a
retail company technology is really at
the center of almost everything that we
do we're investing a lot of energy and
money into technology and in fact 90% of
the software that runs our retail
operations is developed in-house so with
all of these sites and systems and
applications they're generating a lot of
operational telemetry so today I'm going
to talk about our efforts to build a
pipeline to collect and analyze all of
that operational telemetry so what do I
mean by operational tilma tree often we
think of that as things like logs and
metrics and traces from applications
which is true but we've expanded that
definition to include things like
network flows DNS queries logs from
system and servers and network
appliances and also things like
associate systems like registers and
mobile devices in our stores and supply
chain facilities
so why collect all this data what's the
point well a lot of this data can be
used to help us understand our
environment or at least that's the
prevailing theory right but we've really
thought about it in terms of three use
cases so the first is the idea of audit
compliance a lot of the data we collect
because we simply have to we have to
store the data to meet our Sox or PCI or
other sorts of regulations the second
reason that we want this data is for
monitoring and observability more of
these traditional use cases where we
want to make sure that our teams have
the ability to understand what's going
on in their environment and then the
third we want to collect this data and
perform analysis on it to derive
longer-term trends do capacity planning
give us a sense of what's coming in the
future so who benefits from this data
well one of the principles that we
established early on was that we wanted
to collect data once and allow multiple
teams to access that same data it
doesn't make sense to recollect the same
data over and over again so we've
identified three teams that really
find value in the data that we're
collecting the first is our security
team and it's not just for audit
compliance we also collect data for
threat detection and Incident Response
so they can respond to things quickly
the second team is our application
developers they use the data for
troubleshooting and diagnosing their
systems their applications what's going
on in their environment and then the
third would be our infrastructure and
operations team they also use the data
to monitor their environment maybe from
a different perspective and also use it
to think about capacity planning
longer-term trends etc so a few years
ago our attempt to build this particular
system looked a little bit like this so
what we had was a set of third-party and
open source collectors that would
collect all kinds of different data and
ports and protocols and things like that
syslog HTTP etc most of that raw data
fed our calcio pipeline and then we
would take that raw data and put it into
Hadoop for long term storage
and feed it to a set of third-party log
analysis tools for real-time query and
search unfortunately were a number of
challenges for this approach the biggest
challenge was that the increasing data
volume that we were seeing each and
every day we originally built the system
we were anticipating a few terabytes of
data per day but we quickly exceeded
that and we're moving into the tens and
dozens of terabytes of data per day and
all of this data had a significant
impact on our query performance
especially dense data like network flow
traffic or those sorts of things would
take a really long time to complete
hours in some cases and of course that
was a very frustrating experience for
our users
retention periods was also a problem as
the more data we collected we really
couldn't keep up and offer our users the
level of retention they wanted in some
cases we were only able to keep logs for
just a few days which was really
frustrating for teams that wanted to be
able to do comparative analysis which is
really important in a regional
environment we're really interested in
looking at how today looks like compared
to last week or maybe the same day last
month or even the same day last year and
the limits we had in our system
just made it impossible to do those
sorts of analysis and then finally all
this data admit we had all this
infrastructure to deal with and all this
infrastructure meant that we had lots of
problems and loss of time spent dealing
with the infrastructure all of the time
that we were spending dealing on
infrastructure was less time that we
were able to spend taking care of our
users improving their experience I know
you've probably heard the term data Lake
but it when we built this system and all
these challenges that we were
experiencing it felt a little bit more
like a data dumpster we were just
dumping all this data in and we were
really unable to derive any value from
it so we decided it was time for a new
approach and so what we did was we
considered the problem as four steps so
the first step is to collect the data
all that raw data that's floating around
in our environment we need a way to
collect it and we had a pretty good
sense of how to do that the second step
is to transform that data we wanted to
take the raw data turn it into some sort
of usable format it might be semi
structured it might be structured but
somehow we needed to make it usable the
third step was we need to store the data
somewhere stick it somewhere that we
could reason with it interact with it
etc the last step is analyzed and this
is the one that's really really
important the analyze is a word that
gets used a lot but really it's just the
idea that you want to be able to search
and interact and explore your data you
want to have a conversation with it if
you will and we really wanted to make
sure that any system that we decided on
building any system that we developed
allowed our users to have that
conversation with their data so like any
good software engineering problem we cut
the problem in half and what we did was
we decided to keep our collection and
transformation functions in-house which
made sense because we had already spent
a lot of engineering time working on
that problem we had a lot of collectors
and aggregation tiers in place to get
the data and there were so many remote
sites and systems at Home Depot that it
didn't really make sense for all the
systems to send straight to the cloud
the transformation layer also was
something that we we started to keep
in-house because we need to make sure
all the aggregation functions were there
and turn it into some sort of structured
data but the store and analyze functions
we felt like we could move those to the
cloud and that would be a win for us
and so we started looking at ways to do
that and we felt that when we did that
we would be able to optimize cost and
really improve our resource efficiency
if we were able to move the store and
analyze functions to the cloud we felt
like our engineers could spend a lot
more time focused on getting the data in
and making it valuable to our users and
less time on doing the infrastructure
itself plus if we're able to use a
managed service for storing and
analyzing data we felt like we would be
able to really take advantage of the
scale and elasticity of the cloud so
these are sort of the guidelines that we
were considering as we were looking at a
new approach here and so we started our
evaluation process with a number of
different considerations so the first is
what are the features of the platform
that were interested in and first and
foremost we needed to make sure that it
was going to handle our scale we wanted
to make sure that it was gonna start
with the tens of terabytes that we were
getting right when we started but was
going to be able to grow with us for all
the volume and all the variety of data
that we collect we have hundreds of
different data types that we're pulling
in the system we needed to make sure
that it was capable of handling all of
that data and we needed to make sure
that it had multiple modes of ingestion
we also often have cases where we need
to backfill data or bulk load data or
put data into the system in lots of
different ways we also had cases where
we need to stream it in real time and
our users need immediate access to that
data so it was really important that
whatever system we picked had different
ways of getting that data into the
system the second thing we considered
was how well it integrator with other
systems it was important for our users
to have a fairly shallow learning curve
if we adopted a whole new system that
they were going to interact with and so
we wanted something that was at least
familiar with with them and didn't
require a lot of upfront learning and
secondly we wanted to make sure that our
users could bring their own tools to the
data for analytics that might be
anything from a spreadsheet
to BI tools to kurta code we wanted to
make sure that they had those options
available to them and then of course the
third thing was security as we were
moving to a managed service it was
obviously very important for us to
ensure that data was - and from that
system was encrypted and secure and it
was being stored in the same way and of
course we wanted to make sure that our
data was able to be segmented up because
we had these different teams of users
that need access to that data we wanted
to make sure that we could authorize
different users to different segments of
the data and make sure we could split it
up easily and then of course finally
with the managed service we wanted to
make sure it reduces cost and improves
efficiencies and that's the idea behind
a fully managed service we wanted to
ensure that we had a fully managed
service and it wasn't something that we
were going to have to tinker with or
babysit or watch over and of course as a
managed service we wanted to make sure
that it wasn't so narrow and focused
that we could only use it for a few use
cases we wanted to make sure that it
covered as many as possible it might
surprise you learned that big crew was
not in fact the first option that we
considered we actually spent a
significant amount of time evaluating
lots of options and being in the
operational telemetry in law collection
space we started with a lot of services
that are in that space law collection
services as it turned out it big career
was really the only one that met all of
these considerations and so we felt
pretty confident in its ability to cover
all these use cases and we felt like we
could move forward with bigquery as a
managed service as its ability to put
vast amounts of data with without
falling over and we also feel confident
we will go to partner with Google to
discuss or uncover any challenges that
we might expect so this is what we ended
up building and this system is actually
in production right now it's been in
production for about a year what we
ended up doing was we kept our
collections here on Prem same data
systems going into Kafka we replaced the
third-party code that we had doing
transformations with some new code that
we built in-house
and what it does is it takes all of that
raw data and it turns it into structured
data using Avro serialization which is
something that bigquery understands
natively all of those serialized files
are then uploaded to cloud storage and
then we use the bigquery batch loading
API to load the data every 20 seconds
into bigquery one of the reasons that we
wanted to use structured data here is
that it gives us the ability to separate
out our data sets the challenge of the
old system was all the data was in this
you know data dumpster and it was very
difficult to find the data you're
looking for once we were able to
transform the data and to structure data
sets users could go right to the table
they were interested in and start
querying and interacting with their data
so as I mentioned the day this
particular systems been in place for
about a year and we are already seeing
some pretty significant wins the first
of course is data volume and we're
easily able to put tens of terabytes of
data into the system each and every day
and we're confident that we'll be able
to put more and more data as it needs to
go
the second is query performance as we
said earlier our enterprise data
warehouse team was already using
bigquery and so when we selected
bigquery we were able to take advantage
of some organizational economies of
scale one of the ways that we get the
scale from bigquery is we had these
things called query slots which is
basically like a fixed compute engine
with more correa slots you have the
faster performance on bigquery because
the enterprise data warehouse is running
on bigquery and all of our operational
data is on bigquery
both teams are able to take advantage of
that pool of query slots so that whether
you're querying for operational data or
if you're querying for enterprise data
you get to take advantage of the extra
performance that's afforded to each of
the data sets so that was a huge win for
us after we had moved a lot of our data
sets over to bigquery one of my
engineers was working on a problem with
some Network data and he wanted some
help translating his query from the old
system over to the new system
and this was a query that was looking in
like 30 days of network traffic so it
was a fairly large data set and it was
looking at traffic to and from a
particular organization that had maybe
60 or 70 different cider blocks so kind
of a complicated query I'm not that
great at sequel but I said I'll take a
look at it see if I can make it work so
I sat down and tinker with it for a
little bit and I got something running
at least in the system and it seemed to
sort of meet the needs of what he was
looking for but it was running and about
maybe five minutes I didn't know what
his expectations were so I went back to
I said hey I've I've worked on your
query I think it's working it's taking
about five minutes to run so if you want
it to run faster we should probably get
someone else involved who's better at
sequel than me and you said five minutes
are you sure I said yeah I'm sure you
can come look at it
I said why how long was it taking in the
last system his response five hours so
with bigquery the retention period is
another big win for us
retention period of bigquery is really
just a setting it's not months of
infrastructure planning or Hardware
build at least not for us maybe on the
Google side it is but for from our
perspective it's just a setting on the
table and so by default we're able to
offer 90 days by default for all of our
customer data sets and for some data
sets like security days has to keep for
years
and so all of the data sets that we had
before which were only available for a
few days now our teams are able to do
that comparative analysis that they were
asking for so that's been a huge win for
us and infrastructure maintenance by
moving to bigger we are able to
eliminate 10 petabytes of Hadoop
infrastructure which is a really big win
for us so a few observations now that
this system has been running in
production for about a year so I
mentioned some of the custom code that
we were writing we tried really hard to
stick with third-party and open source
code for as long as possible
writing these custom codes takes longer
than you think it will it always kind of
runs you run into a lot of unexpected
problems more frequently than you think
you will and so we tried really hard to
stick with that custom code for as long
as possible
only write our own custom code when we
really had to the second thing is use
managed services where possible with
bigquery there's a whole class of
problems that I don't have to think
about how data is stored how its
replicated all the search and query
performance and the engineering behind
that that's all something that the
Google team gets to worry about I get to
just take advantage of that architecture
and so it's now easy for us to load tens
of terabytes today the data retention is
simply a setting for table and our query
performance is from hours and days down
to seconds and minutes all of these
things are really good but even in our
current system there are some things
that we want to improve the first thing
is that we experienced some delays and
data availability I mentioned this is
for operational data operational data is
like firehose it never ever stops and so
if there's any problem in our pipeline
what tends to happen is the recent data
gets stuck behind all of the data that
was in before it and so we get this
backlog of data where users are sort of
twiddling their thumbs waiting on their
data it's not a very good experience for
them also on one of the PSAPs earlier
slides there's a comment says free bulk
loading which is true up to a point when
you're loading this much data you
actually have to get these things called
load slots which are these sort of
compute units that allow you to load
lots and lots of data into bigquery in
batch mode as it turns out these load
slots are a little bit difficult to
predict we have this huge firehose of
data so we need sand data can be
difficult to predict and it can be tough
to make sure that we're not going to
have an operational impact when we have
that giant burst of data also and
somewhat unfortunately load slots are
incompatible with query slots so we were
put in the sort of awkward position of
trying to spend resources on either load
slots or query slots improving load
times or improving query times so that
was something that we wanted to address
on the next evolution of this
architecture the other thing that we
experienced was a lot of quota
and resource limits and things that we
ran into as we started building the
system we would run into one quota work
with the team to get it adjusted in
their own head first with the next one
so there's a lot of things that need to
be tuned and adjusted to deal with the
scale and volume of data that we were
interested in we also weren't nearly
creative enough thinking about the types
of failures that we might run into
building the system one good example is
that we started with using regional
buckets on cloud storage for all of
those ever files one regional outage
taught us so quickly moved to
multi-regional storage the second thing
is to really think about fault domains
one mistake we made building the system
was we built essentially one giant
pipeline that was a mistake because any
impact in the system impacted all of our
customers so one of the things that
we're working on is splitting that up
into smaller fault domains to limit the
number of people that are mad at us at
any given time so the design for the new
system is actually already done and it's
in testing right now and the plan is to
move to it in the next few months so
this is what our next phase of the
architecture looks like we're
essentially moving more to a streaming
model one of the things that we did was
that we rewrote our collection tier we
had all this third-party and open source
tools that we were using and it was
becoming more complicated and more
difficult to manage so we wrote our own
collection tier which gave us the
ability to classify data as it was being
streamed in and that way we were able to
separate this data out as it feeds into
Kafka and then we could upload that data
already classify it up into cloud
storage that gave us a single ingestion
tier to worry about and we're able to
get consistent stats and performance
across the entire tier from there the
process is very similar all the data
that goes into cloud storage it is
already in those Avro files that I
talked about earlier but once the file
is created we generate a notification
that goes into pub/sub our
transformation tier is now running on
kubernetes engine and so it's just using
a pulse description to listen for those
notifications once it gets one it reads
the
from cloud storage the streams the data
into bigquery some of the advantages of
this new system we're getting much
faster date availability with bigquery
streaming than we were with the batch
loads in some cases data is now
available in seconds as opposed to
minutes because we've moved a lot of our
transform workload over to gke we're now
able to take advantage of things like
kubernetes pot auto scaling to grow and
shrink our compute resources over the
course of a day and this particular
model addresses the problem of the last
model which was the data getting stuck
behind that older data so how does that
work let me dive into that for just a
second so the way this works is we built
essentially two paths for these
notifications and the notifications only
use one path at a time so as the data is
streamed up and written into cloud
storage we generate those notifications
on either the a path or the B path if
one path starts getting behind or
there's a backlog or any sort of problem
just like a railroad switch we just
switch the notifications to the
secondary path and from there all the
recent data can be streamed into
bigquery and the backlog data can just
flow in as it was flowing in before but
this gives us the opportunity to keep
recent data recent and available for our
users so a few lessons learned from our
experience building the system the first
thing is keep it simple
there's a lot of complexity in the
system already there's a lot of options
out there a lot of tools and things to
play with and tinker with but we only
started with two cloud services when we
built the system cloud storage and
bigquery that was it and we didn't move
forward with any additional cloud
services and so we felt like we had
really understood those services and the
impact of those services was going to
have on the overall system
all of the additional complexity that
you add to the system means that your
failures are going to be more complex
it's more your team has to learn so it's
really important to keep it simple using
those fault domains to limit the impact
it's another good lesson for us
simplicity and how many things can go
wrong will limit the overall impact to
the system when something does and
evidently go wrong the second thing is
make sure you iterate your zine you've
seen a couple of different evolutions of
our architecture and what we're about to
implement and I'm sure there'll be
changes down the road as well you want
to plan for failures in your system it's
not going to be perfect from day one we
certainly learn that we want to use
those feathers to help iterator design
and make those incremental improvements
a lot of the quotas and limits and stuff
that we ran into a lot of those can be
adjusted so it's important to stay
aligned with your customer engineering
team to make sure that you kind of stay
ahead of those particular limits and
then consider your workload placement
over time it doesn't have to be the case
that all of your workload moves to the
cloud from day one we certainly didn't
we started with a hybrid model we're
continuing with a hybrid model we have a
lot of workload that runs on from
removing different pieces to the cloud
as it fits our particular use case and
you should feel free to do the same
thing that is a good model to work with
and lastly focus on value and what I
mean by this is really think more about
outcomes and what you're trying to get
to for your customers then the
engineering effort a lot of times we get
excited by the engineering and that's ok
there's a lot of fun toys to play with
here but it's important to really think
about the outcome of what you're trying
to get to when you're using something
like big courier is a managed service
it's important to realize that there's a
lot of things you don't have to worry
about you can immediately start having
that conversation with your data and
your users I will benefit and then of
course think about ways to cut the
problem in half to leverage your
partners and to make sure
you're able to continue to use them as
sort of an extension of your engineering
team as you focus on those outcomes so
that's really it we my team has
certainly learned a lot building the
system and hopefully some of these
experiences will be helpful for you if
you're considering something similar
[Music]